[Music]
you
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you about god's little
acre seeds of love are planted on god's
little acre all the mess they worked in
they pray to their maybe need a proper
goal they won't be partaker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
why not blue perfect hell did that don't
have to break loose up there Justin
we're getting deep ain't that something
I'm getting kind of tired digging this
hole can we start what fight what do you
mean what fir we've been digging in this
one for two months already par we ain't
struck nothing yet but a lot of hard
work so I've been digging in this land
close to 15 years and I'm aiming to dig
15 mark need be trouble you boys you
ain't found a patient sir I don't need
no patients what we need is a diviner
there you go again talking superstition
all you talk about is diviners and
conjures and stuff like that son
anything the way of superstition how you
take me I'm sad to go so scientific puff
why don't you get us a big machine Pole
and get the job done I ain't gonna buy
nothin to cost money I can't afford it
where you going son
quit for a day Paul I know why shop and
go to tear never get rich that way I
don't really get rich I'm too young
[Music]
worried about that boy go see in town oh
you ain't pick anything with skirts on
you need Yost of women yet they can do
him harm you won't know about it - it's
too late to stop the clock
[Music]
why Thank You Dylan off
[Music]
which cut for dinner honey flames
yesterday over bacon fat and breast I'd
like me some fried chicken man has a
wife like Griselda don't know how I can
keep it mine and food all the time now
quit teasing tighter
the good Lord seen fit to put a beauty
like you in our house
I'm gonna take my filler looking like
you my lucky cuz they got a wife we're
doing love me what you two lovebirds got
to hug you back she hardly talks to me
anymore
too busy daydreaming about will Thompson
if you'd quit throwing his name up to me
maybe I'd get a chance to forget it well
we'll have to do is snap his fingers and
you go running you keep on this way buck
and you wake up some fine morning all by
your lonesome you don't mean actors ever
tell buck you don't mean that you tell
him I want to hear mention will Thompson
[Music]
I know the trouble is she's still
[Music]
charlie is right down there and that big
hole thank you
sure is hot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
pretty soon no feeling but you folks
coming here nearly a year and you see me
and you didn't know what I was digging
for you think I don't clean out of my
hand I'm digging for gold gold in the
state of Georgia right yeah gold gold
coins big around as a biscuit gone forks
go thunder bugs you'd be surprised you
seen him for a fact almost way
don't know exactly I be fine they're
better grandpa won't you buy you will
determine the very day he died
[Music]
well maybe you might have been mistaken
my grandpa had to be alive I can't stand
it's alive
you got a clicking sound of gold yet
what you folks need is an out burner to
help you out
why did tell me a man ain't got much
chance to snowball in hell without
burner to help him find something what
albino
what in the blue perfect hell is that
why is one of these all white man looks
like they made out of chalk why does
cotton got white hair white skin white
eyeballs even you fellas need one week
I'm bad no clue I'm scientific all the
way through I wouldn't have nothing to
do with country but I ain't talking
about no conjurer Ty Ty
I'm talking about an albino why they got
a secret power they can see right
through the ground that was glass of
water strictly scientific
convinced
you got me convinced I know as a citizen
and a voter you time up be sure you
don't do nothing to break the law but if
you do mention me out cause there's a
future share for this count just how big
a man is what's not our baby as that
counts it's the whiteness of him his
blood is white the wax in his ears just
why god I'm gonna get there a white man
if I have to bust a gut get me what
you'll get on up to the house pick up
[Music]
people you came by here today oh yes
your minds to where I've been missing
outsider to show me exactly where that
gold is buried what hit boys do a Katy
just like you said
well sure I can I'll borrow my rectify
motion well he might just walk see where
all that gold is bed
right there anyway
god's little acre put this cross here to
mark the spot waited 27 years that's
right
dad's married I promised this piece of
land of the Holiness Church everything
that grows here they can have cotton
drawn anything else
if that grounds so second where do you
take the cross out first
cuz it just occurred to me Flula I never
had going down a home Gosselin labor not
all these years but saloons like you
said that albino walks out on my farm
and points to that land there goes I
think um fell by my conscience to give
all that gold away to the preacher what
yet maybe I wouldn't give him that what
are you gonna do with it
I'm gonna move god's little acre a spot
where don't stand out in the open it's a
sin and a temptation
[Music]
God please forgive me I had to move you
little late to put myself out of
temptation I'm going up there
and sorely tempted not to turn it over
to you you wouldn't want me in
temptation I know that I don't mean to
cheat you know well no I don't you can
have anything that grows on this piece
of ground flowers are honey
is that watermelon cool and wrap and
ready-to-eat showers
but let's all go in the house and get
some of that cool water
come on okay there's a whole mess of
votes between here in a crossroads I
just gotta get a beautiful you're so
small and your face is so red look
exactly like a watermelon Susie knows
she needs some peace treaty to far away
do you any good
and she man besides - we'll talk
court she married - I sometimes wonder
if [ __ ] is a right and proper husband
for girls beautiful it's Cruz elder even
if he is my own flesh and blood
so that leave my baby
darn Jill but she's too young to go
court I don't want a quarter I wanna
marry her you would you mean
I cut off my right arm to matter huh you
taking a liking to it Pluto sure to God
have a nice effect one thing kind of
bothers me what's that well I heard
shipping teasing a fool around with a
lot of men I heard why darling
Jill is a favorite of family and she's
grown up at last she sure has that's a
pity God can make a woman like darling
Jill and leave off before it goes too
far hey no when he made enough of a good
thing they just kept on and on now look
at her no man look don't you like to see
something that's only natural the way I
said Mona's got to teach something
father settle down to bed and babies
there's a lot better to do it now they
have to get married
she changed oh it's up to you to satisfy
and make us so happy and she leave off
with everybody with you Oh already when
we just go huh we'll waiting for downs
you darling you won't get back - she
rides over loose trucking sumbitch Oh
it's 12 hours that swapping back what
I'd like to do is get that our bottle
and get back here so I can go to town
son I'm mighty proud to hear you say you
want to be up in jewels do many people
in this world just want to sit around
their butts and wait for the column to
grow well not me and not my son we're in
a hurry to get rich in the kasha
I want to ask you a favor well I can't
do no favors without the car just don't
bring your car back you know that and
when she does I want you to drive her a
peach street Valley what about me Paul I
want to go to I don't want to hang
around here everlastingly waiting for
something to happen you stay here I'll
go with my place to go can't wait to see
will again Kenya what I just get to
telling you but she goes to see will
Thompson over my dead body
I want you to stay here grisel and cook
us a mess of food wait for us to come
back you tell Gonz you'll to go to
Peachtree Valley and get Rosalyn there
husband will and come back to the farm
where she was born golden and make us
all rich again for your help me flute oh
I reckon I can tip you let there be a
tunnel or any that to be true no that
ain't even up to Diamond Jim that's up
to you get your car going but I'm not
going till she promises to stay here I'm
not promising anything now buck why
don't you use your charm ask a nice like
ask it won't hurt you I'm asking you to
stay Grizelda you asking me or telling
me he's asking you let him say it
I'm asking you GU Zelda alright I'll
stay
let's go pull
[Music]
you know darling
[Music]
[Music]
well what do we have to do that for Don
Jill all right now come straight ahead
laughs big horse head now right left
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't kill I don't even know what I'm
doing here
st. even a right stick for me to get let
then let on the right time and it's hot
good let's go home I count some votes
well the kind of manic he their way
around you should take none of them
what did will do to you where is he yeah
let me take the clothes off this chair
sit down make yourself to hold for I've
got it go ride home that's a fact
shut up and sit down yeah Rosemont tell
me what happened you can talk in front
of Pluto they caught him not way to me
he's been drunk or Weeki drinks whenever
he can I wouldn't mind that so much it
it's just that he won't stay home with
me no one sleeps all day goes out it now
oh it ain't his fault
it's for the meal it's been closed down
now for six months he's got nothing in
the world to do well ain't he never
going to open again I recognize they say
it don't pay a dividend no more it's
bankrupt this whole town is bankrupt we
ought to all just pack up and move away
right now
Oh hope we don't everybody looks up to
will he won't move he says he's gonna
open the mill again somehow well you
don't know how well I'm glad I came
Paul wants you and will to come home and
help him dig he's got sure way to find
grandpa's goal this time
if there was don't you think they'd have
found it long for now
I can't Paul quit digging that land full
of holes and and try to raise corn or
cotton of peanuts like everybody else -
well I don't know about that but Paul
wants you and will to come home well dig
god no farm
she's not a farm boy oh no that paddies
time I don't need no boy else coming
home tonight
well they will just sit here and wait
for him we'll spend enough that's
another fine idea
we'll spend the night not quite so fine
all that I'm gonna sleep you on the bed
with Roseman and you'd make yourself a
pallet on the floor
darlin Jill let me look at you the life
baby's a full-grown woman love is a
peach and a branch ripe and ready to
pluck we don't take home that way you
sure look like everything just fine with
you well
[Music]
wait gone
trying to slip away were you ain't dad a
sneaky thing to do come back here lolly
and keep me company
how's Brazil she's still married
you know Pluto Walker Zelda the first
pair high-heeled shoe Sheldon was
working in the mail and she walked
around in them high-heeled shoes it
wasn't a man got a full day's work that
well please don't talk about it now
a girl drizelda Pluto we almost got
married she wanted me to go groot and
grub on the farm I wouldn't do it I'm a
town boy I got a B where I can hear
factory whistle blow three times a day
watch those crowds of girls come running
out of the company gate laughs and
screaming raising Cain face is like food
like flowers well you've gotta realize
something what's it for all never gonna
open again and Griselda's married keep
doing nothing back
I can't sleep well you can rest
turn out the lights or portraiture eyes
[Music]
I will who's that coming to car to your
house well Rosalyn's people what they
come just for visit ain't come to take
away have they will I promise I wouldn't
leave B Street alley until it stopped
the cotton mill a carriage at night and
will I know it's easy fuel response will
upstate in fact just to you most trust
got big family we ain't got the money to
moving find jobs house it somewhere else
[Music]
ain't gonna leave us boys he's gonna
stay right in town
[Music]
you drinking again I want to get in
why you always coming here for I want to
get in nothing here but a closed-down
cotton mill now what are you looking for
you know what I'm looking for floor time
looking for the day when the light
shines almost rivers that days gone will
the mill ain't never gonna open up again
spindles are still threaded power still
connected all it takes is with somebody
to pull a switch on that's crazy talk
wheel why don't you go home before your
wife has to come looking for you gear
don't tell me what to do I know what I
have to do what do you say you go down
to Ned's bar and get yourself a drink
yeah have it on me
he leaks Jessie how's my
mana Dave you sleep well
you with friends
went to love it plus and bother to get
you appreciated hungry you get your
breakfast in due time
first you get work to do what kind of
work it's easy actually you take this
it's Willa Fork
till she blows you down scientifically
speaking right down to where the gold is
surely located you looking for gold why
do you think we come clean down the
swamp corners to let sue you I still
don't know you're a genuine our binary
yeah I reckon I am
what would I be doing with an albino
except to find gold ain't gonna do it
why not son cuz I don't know how now you
listen to me son you don't know how to
define gold
you better start going in right now all
these nice folks are gonna be pretty mad
at you and we won't get no business with
it I just can't I can't
I'm sorry I got angry soon but I I've
been digging for gold for 15 years and I
ain't gonna give up I don't know what to
do take this will mistake that's it turn
your wrists up that's right put it out
front
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
amen amen
now maybe mr. TyTy you'll stop digging
and start farm I can't honestly say it
is minute before they found the gold
something come over me I decided to
change the location of god's little acre
just about in time a racket where's it
now paw
[Music]
Lord ain't told me that well tell them
the hurry about going to drop like it
good Lord in your car we're all fashion
we got to take our time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now God I don't need to cheat you no
sweat
but with this unseasonable weather
I believe you didn't matter have your
egg in a cooler spot
if you don't like this you don't approve
of what I'm doing Lord and strike me
down dead right here where I stand
[Music]
thank you lord
maybe
are we home no but we put a mile away
why are we stopping for Dawn Jill I just
gotta have an answer
jonno murder don't you know I'm ready
I'm ready enough for both of us
I'll marry you any time day time all the
time if your belly want so big you
couldn't be sheriff and if you weren't
gonna be share I'll fight evening look
cute don't you just because I'm so crazy
lovers I can't hardly see nothing else
there's no reason that some day I just
don't get to round up and so provoked I
just don't take my two hands for a
minute I thought you're gonna darn your
socks again
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good to see
you look like you just stepped out of
County look like Hale will what you've
been doing yourself doing absolutely
nothing boys absolutely not what will
needs Rosa Mendes to occupy himself with
something useful you know well there's
nothing better for man's body and spirit
and digging down and God's good earth
grows when you go in the house and help
each other warm upbeat flute oh here
he's he's just about stop you know
nothing makes a man hungrier than having
his whole family around man that sure
get some men just hole you duh what's
that in it vote okay why that's at all
what man you put me on great guns Pluto
Betsy I buy no we wrote from the swamp
did you define for you just like falling
for make see now you're gonna have crazy
digging right beside the house it's
gonna topple over into that hole it
won't fall down we kind of will be rich
enough to build a house three times the
size what are you looking at down here
well I'm looking to see that our by no
man I never seen one for my life just
the same as you and me can you talk talk
yeah I'm allowed to give me every change
I wanna see just what's calm up here I
don't even have nobody fool with him
could just walk off and call crows if
that's what you got in mind
he's got to stay in a job for me all the
time now you come on into the house I'm
coming
hello there albino fella
my name is Dave doesn't tell any lies
about your color party color - I like it
thank you ma'am the first time words
I've heard you're kidnapping with a
string of Lies and another plow line now
that I got such a good look at you would
you like to come up here
they say you're beautiful mm-hmm
I want you come on up here say that
again
get him shy and scared miss Donna and
Jim he might run away I don't feel like
chasing after him with my shotgun oh he
won't run away uncle Felix I promised
your dad come on dad
Crowley gonna go out watch the moon rise
over the pond come on don't you like me
Oh God gosh I'm REI I just didn't know
there was a crew as pretty as you in in
the whole country I mean I mean you're
the prettiest girl I've ever seen and
you talk like a birdsong you smell good
you talk talk to me what do you want me
to say I don't know some people say it's
because I've made in the wine of the
moon wonderful looking I'm glad you're
so different I get some tired the same
looking people every day of my life
would you like to kiss me well yeah I
would if you let me recognize just
couldn't help myself
[Music]
we aware me kiss me once oh me too
[Music]
my name
what's the Barracuda he left all in
clear how many grits on the table some
would attack
where's Don Jill she'd right here a
minute
now you've got me worried oles have been
gone half an hour
Oh lot can happen in a half an hour just
like what well but one thing I don't
know
and another thing maybe they just took
off to another County and got made now
you got me really worried God just crazy
enough to do anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you find them well did you well you
know Pluto
seems to me like these boys that have
more sense and I like tight tie a guy
minute digging empty holes in the ground
la piel in a lousy Lin head ain't no
more goal in that ground and their
reason the toes on my socks
your boys wise up and go to Atlanta
Guster some will come from your boys
[Applause]
wonderful Furby hell you two got to
fight about told you're gonna be pretty
cold for all of it
Paul he wasn't fighting about the gold
so he acts and talks like he's better
than we are time he comes over here pie
he admitted invites a beatin boys it's a
shame we can't keep a peaceful family
that's what happened a man all my life
to have and if I can't have it I swear
I'm gonna leave there go where it is and
go back to greven cop and you tell him
to stop Tomcat around my wife you're
telling this I didn't know you don't say
nothin he just looks and that's play
looks don't hurt anybody but he's
getting ready to start something I know
that much really you get in the house
now buck that's just your imagination
will ain't after Griselda I made up my
mind about that kill nobody not my land
or any place else
now you get up in the ground and cool
off get off heat it up down this hole
take fresh air to get it out of you
now go on go on up the house go on the
show come on [ __ ] it
tell him to go home yeah
[ __ ] right I oughta go I hope you don't
mean that will now I found the right
spot I'm gonna need all the help I can
get right spot the house you want to
topple right into this hole if you dig
anymore
I gotta go home I gotta get that meal
started that ain't what you think
you're thinking about Griselda it ain't
no sin to think well you're gonna kill
yourself you go on that way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I couldn't sleep
[Music]
[Music]
I guess we did the right thing
[Music]
yes
what
[Music]
[Music]
Dave are you sure your divine the golden
just the right place you saw the will of
point down didn't you
we're gonna lie why should scientific
mr. tighter you ought to be out raising
cotton you are good for me that is you
used to be I'm it the time tie you can
raise more cutting on this land in one
season then you can find gold in a whole
lifetime it's a waste of everything mr.
tied tied digging them holes all over
the place well now I wish I had spent
more time on the cotton for sure twenty
or thirty bales to tide me over the fall
and winter I could devote all the rest
of my time to dig a tire where are we
gonna get enough grub to care us to
another winner we use my credit sorry
man says you ain't got enough credit
left degrees again to your nose
Felix I'm sorry about there but there's
nothing I can do you can't stop the
fever
well mr. kite I if it's as bad as all
that
why don't you go up to Augusta and
borrow some money from your son Jim
Leslie I wouldn't be no sense in that
why not mr. cha I can tell he's rich
anyhow all the same he wouldn't help me
man Felix my son Jim Leslie won't speak
to me on the street if he won't speak to
me on his feet I know darn well he won't
lend me money
you're his Pappy ain't You mr. tighter I
reckon so
Jim Leslie ain't been a bad name ain't
been a good one Thank You practically a
stranger that's wrong either go see him
just to keep the family ties together
but I keep feeling mister you just gotta
get some money real quick how you're
gonna keep it all on the farm why we'll
all have to go someplace else to work to
make a living
Felix yes mr. tie-dye I just got a
wonderful idea
I'm gonna call my gym Leslie you know
he's my son he's a rich man
he's a cotton broker and no son of mine
is gonna stand by ladies King go hungry
Felix
mr. Takei
what are you doing oh you don't reckon
I'm gonna run away from ya I've never
been so happy in all my born days
hey son you get up and and get going do
what you say
did any meet a talking boy it's just
gone now you get up and get going
and head straight for your home back to
the squad you know what you ain't gonna
shoot me are you no I ain't gonna shoot
nobody son but there's gone Mike I don't
want to go I'm sorry son but you got to
go it's the only way I know how to say
this one now you get going
[Music]
we're inside
I got thrown aside now I'm lazy lizard
Feinstein all right I'm mighty proud of
way my voice made his way in a world
[Music]
[Music]
that's
biggis a winter session
almost as beautiful as a new clock the
common side I put on a highway coming
into Georgia Oh Brad
Taemin a [ __ ] mustard took I do
those leaves no we need a picture spend
a half-dollar and gasoline drive into
the woods to see the really happy with
more money we were going far
you
even son what are you doing here son you
you know you pleased to see it don't put
on it you're not funny I didn't handy
Dobel you don't ring no bells in my
family you just walk in that's the way
we're doing my family we're never gonna
do any different
nobody has to knock on my door ring no
fancy bells to get in the house what'd
he come here for my master oh well why
don't you dig it out to grab a nice
waited to talk you're only dad well
that's what you came here for isn't it
money well isn't it no not at all
all I need is the where was older
goodbye feed and seed for my
sharecroppers so that I can dig down
another 20 feet and locate my grandpa's
go well there's no gold there you know
that you know it as well as I do do you
Otto you've been digging for 15 years
you'll be digging holes on the day you
die
alright there's the money now take it
and go on home
then got into you jim leslie an early
age you're different from the rest of us
I don't know why you like like your
shame to me but I don't see how that can
be because I'm your father
would you take on like like you don't
know who I am
where you from well I'm sorry for you
son you married a widow not because you
loved you just had to have it not
because you got caught with the bases
loaded by her part no you got married
just to get you a house and a fortune
well your wife's dead man and all you
got left is a house full of breakable
thick
well son I guess we better be going
ba why don't you fix yourself a drink I
don't take a drink son whether some
fresh fruit in our dining room aren't
you going and help yourself I don't mind
if I do
are you too darling yeah there's elder
go go man
Dinan way down there that's rap all
right down there
Fidel at some time in your town come up
to see me it's my office I want you to
come I wouldn't do that
why not because it isn't right that's
why I'm gonna be looking for just the
same Griselda you want to come up and
see me no I'm not
after that you only pair shoes you come
up and see GM Leslie you buy you the
horse you stole you don't come singing
I'm gonna come out there and get you
here I want to come out to their pig
belly farm and bring you right back to
this house but if you did you have four
kids by now
now when you're not all imported
Griselda's got to stop that apologize
for Jim Leslie Brazil de my family ain't
known for their politeness to women
headstrong that way
come on I'll be coming out there and get
you one of these days Brazil thanks for
the money soon considered alone
did you get it Paul did you get it huh
I reckon I did look at this big wad of
greenbacks hey Paul you know what I'd
like to get now I'd like to get me uh
I'd like to get me a rain coat what fer
well it's fixing the rainfall we can't
rain
I didn't want to rain yet away I got
digging that hole and I can't dig
underwater any too well
yeah before suppose it does right I like
to put me on a raincoat whenever it
starts to rain you just peel off your
clothes and let your skin take care of
the rest
god never made a final rink over the
mens skin anyhow let's go I'm kind of
thirsty we can stop in town and get a
quick beer well I don't think he'd be
shown the proper respect for Jim
Leslie's money suspended mr. loo just
one bit one beautiful I never been to
saloon my life ain't gonna start now
well wait in the car for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I apologize man but I was only trying to
get my family out of that saloon you
made me come all the way down here for
nothing
[Music]
[Music]
well he tried he tried to drink will
under the table for and I guess he lost
it's all water ride in our own backyard
my health and long life it's just plain
well water now you'll get will Rosamund
and we'll be on our way hi you beautiful
way to keep your heads off
[Music]
I'm sorry I had to do that son of one
Rosamond you and we'll have to go back
to Peachtree Valley I don't seem to be
able to keep my family together
[Music]
Oh uncle Felix told me he went to
Jimenez this house and I went there soon
Jimenez he said go to the first bar come
to be there drinking up his money
whatever you mean how much did you mr.
feller I've got his boat oh you
everlasting horse head Jim lizard don't
even live in the right County to make it
vote count that effect Luna I couldn't
be happier to see you is that a fast
yeah you come with just about the right
time how did you and down Gilligan drive
will Rosamund back to Peachtree Valley
oh I'm gonna pull a switch and light up
the whole world tonight yes me like I'm
a baby switch I'm gonna pull a switch
light up the whole world
well I'm afraid to go back home it's not
never been this while he's gonna do
something I know six months now I just
been living from day to day hoping that
tomorrow a change him but I gotta have
help now I can't do it alone
Grizelda you're the only one who might
listen to Azula she can't go absolutely
please make Rosetta listen to me
Zelda has to make up our own mom don't
ask who can I ask hate you hate him too
no you know I do
you love same site that's why you've got
to help him Chris I will please I'm
begging you please please
alright I'll go with you till he Sobers
up
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank goodness it is dark I wasted
another day haven't counted a single
vote I've got a big getting home ice
cream getting too cold to eat wait just
a little while longer
till he wakes up he's mighty fond of
peach ice cream too rules my bucks gonna
be what stay a while I don't want to be
here alone with him are you scared
wait until I woke up didn't you
yes well turning on the power a night
well wouldn't you like some peach ice
cream never worked in the cotton mill
did you no sir I've got to be getting
home
I've got to get elected it it's not
important will you know what it's like
in a company town when there's no work
no sir
you have a shoot of rabbit go and pick
him up and when you lifted him up in
your hand felt his hot pounding like I
don't know what have you
well I have
I have
[Music]
[Music]
hi well what you gonna do wanna break
open the gates and turn on the power
[Music]
[Music]
don't shut
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's all here the same day I left waste
nothing but waste
[Music]
we're selling the powers on the valley
hummus is meat the potatoes on every
table remember for the things to laugh
see what I mean
you see why why I got to turn on the
power I've been talking about it too
long takes a man to turn on the power
line just a talker just looking at you
makes me feel like a man again look at
me
you sound like Rosalie I don't do it now
never do it I'll do anything
I gotta film this close before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know
get everybody a nice cool glass of water
here
those month why don't you just said in
the porch wrestler
[Music]
I want to know what's the matter with
you not then act as if they just buried
your husband stepdad Lin hen please buck
please what don't want me to talk about
it huh let you care about Roseman no
one's eaten in this hostel I get an
answer from huh I asked you a question
can't you talk it's a shame you can't
kill a man but once otherwise I'd be
gunning for him right now I don't like
to kill myself you are ashamed yourself
[ __ ] you shut up you don't look ashamed
for anything
you're both alike a pair loose filling
if you ain't man enough to hold on to
your wife I'd be ashamed admit I just go
hide my face someplace
[Music]
all of us ought to sit down and think a
little God didn't put us here scrap and
fight each other all the time I don't
want to hear no more about God we don't
have a little more love for each other
there's gonna be a real sorrow in your
heart son I've tried all my life to keep
a peaceful family under my roof if you
just stop fighting learn to smile and
laugh just a little you talk like an old
fool maybe it sounds that way to you if
you got the feeling that God in your
heart you just can't find God God God
what did God have it do for you
I don't feel exactly [ __ ] does but we
ain't got a penny out of Gaza liquor
here boys don't seem to catch on it's
not important that I get money out of
god's little acre fact I can walk out I
stand on it feel God is there what's all
this got to do with me Grizelda your
boys seem to think about if the things
you can see and touch well that ain't 11
so things you feel down inside you
that's what livings right if you felt
more huh Griselda feels inside her no
other man could touch it that's just
what I was getting at before you shut
your fool mouth off what went on between
you and before he died
how's it gonna make you feel any better
to ever tell you that I want to hear
from her I got a right to that up now
I'm not afraid to tell him you know I
don't tell him anything expand why would
you well I went to bed tonight I'd get
down on my knees in the dark and try
talking to God a little he can tell you
things nobody else can and maybe to tell
you how you ought to act with gizelle do
you tell you if you only take the time
and trouble to listen but there's
anything in the world he's crazy about
it it's in a man and woman in love with
each other to forgive this part of them
when he sees that he knows the world is
running of longus like his crease
but Coco gets a little over you just
trying to be patient with a little bit
longer you take some people almost a
lifetime to learn some things
I'm afraid you'll never learn what's a
to learn will wasn't any bigger than I
am
it wasn't any strong either I could
throw him any morning before breakfast
no way look that made him different buck
it was the way who was made inside he
could feel things and you can't you
can't suck me in with that kind of talk
I want to know what you and will did
behind my back Pluto what happened what
do you mean by nothing much which just
means nothing much and so did you go
deaf dumb and blind the day you went to
peachtree valley i was in that house the
whole time were there I don't see
nothing more exciting than coffee and
cake and peach ice cream then that siren
blue we all knew that wheel was dead
that's a fact
now that settled let's go in and get
some sex
I'll get a good night's rest tomorrow
things look a lot different Longbourn
Dustin
I got a big empty house oh bloody a room
for you - Rosamond
now look here son you're welcome to stay
for supper but you're so all-fired and
getting back to Augusta you go on don't
be tempting the girls they're staying
here you know it looks like all you
learn your lesson by now all you've
raised on this land is piles of dirt and
empty holes I am to strike a load soon
you've been saying the same thing for
years age didn't bring you any more
sense
I got sense you don't know about son I
hate the smell of this place
I hated that since the day I was born
you can come live with me and Casta
Grizelda you can have some new clothes
and money getting a Hasker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you get out you get in your car Jeff
Lesley
go back to Augusta where you belong you
ever show your face here again son of
mine are no son of mine
got a house get some shopping some good
night's sleep maybe tomorrow I'll be a
good day
[Music]
God give me strength
spread out my arms to the end of my
fields
we make the land smooth
you spared my sons
to plant seeds for things to grow
[Music]
and you big Horsehead of a chef laughter
be
you plant well shot I'm planting
oh where do we go for dinner honey
say yes bacon fat and grill I don't care
I just want to be waited on by a
beautiful woman
what's the matter mr. tighter what are
you nothing but a rock mr. chaichol game
it sounded like metal I swear it did
give me room where's nothing but an old
shovel mr. Takei a bit it's a hundred
years old I bet you my grandpa use this
shovel to bury the gold it's a sign from
the Lord
mr. Tata if we're gonna have a crop this
year
we got a whole lot more plow into do you
reckon there'd be much time lost if I
just took this day to give him a grand
for one more chance dr. Lee
come on mule
[Music]
[Music]
now I've told you about god's little
acre now i told you about god's little
acre
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]